a very important idea that people are
often unaware of in falsi fact that we
have two completely different ways of
seeing the world two different neural
networks we access when we're perceiving
things so what this means is when we
first sit down to learn something for
example we're going to study math you
sit down and you focus on it so you
focus and you're activating task
positive Network and then what happens
is you're working away and then you
start to get frustrated you can't figure
out what's going on and what's happening
is you're focusing and you're using one
small area of your brain to analyze the
material but it isn't the right circuit
to actually understand and comprehend
the material so you get frustrated you
finally give up and then we give up and
get your attention off it it turns out
that you activate a completely different
type of or set of neural circuits that's
the default mode network and the related
neural circuits so what happens is you
stop thinking about it
you will acts you go off for a walk you
take a shower you're doing something
different and in the background this
default mode network is doing some sort
of neural processing on the side and
then what happens is you come back and
Allah probably the information makes
sense and in fact they can subtly seem
so easy that you can't figure out why
you didn't understand it before so
learning often involves going back and
forth between these two different neural
modes focus mode and what I often call
diffuse mode which involves those neural
resting States you can only be in one
mode at the same time so you might
wonder is there a certain task that is
more appropriate for focus mode or
diffuse mode the reality
that learning involves going back and
forth between these two modes you often
have to focus at first in order to
certain sort of load that information
into your brain and then you do
something different get your attention
off it and that's when that background
processing occurs and this this happens
no matter what you're learning whether
you're learning something in math and
science you're learning a new language
or the music a dance even learning to
back up a car and think about it this
way here's a very important important
related idea and that is that when
you're learning something new you want
to create a well practiced neural
pattern that you can easily draw to mind
we need it
so this is called a neural chunk and
chunking theory is incredibly important
in learning so for example if you are
trying to learn the back up a car when
you first begin it's crazy right you're
looking all around deal can this mirror
this mirror or do you look behind you
what do you do it's this crazy set of
information but after you've practiced
awhile you develop this very nice sort
of pattern that's well practiced so all
you have to do is think I'm going to
back up a car instantly that pattern
comes to mind and you're able to back up
a car not only are you doing that but
you may be talking to friends listening
the radio it's that well practice neural
chunk that makes it seem easy so it's
important in any kind of learning to
create these well practice patterns and
the bigger the library of these patterns
the more well practice sort of deeper
and broader they are as neural patterns
in your mind the more expertise you have
in that topic and chanting was first
sort of thought of or explored by Nobel
Prize winner Simon who who found that if
if you're a chess man
stir that the higher your ranking in
chess the more patterns of chess you had
memorized so you can access more and
more patterns of chess so research begin
developing and what they found was that
the better your expertise if anything
the more solid neural patterns what I
call neural chunks you have so for
example if you might know how to do
mathematics very well well you've got
certain patterns related to
multiplication and you've practiced
quite a bit with them and so you can put
them instantly to mind
and likewise division and then you go
higher so you've got
calculus you've got the concept of the
limit you've got integrals derivatives
and you practice with each one of those
enough so that it is almost like backing
up a car all you have to do is think oh
I've got to take this derivative and
boom off you go you're taking the
derivative and it seems very easy to you
so a challenge that we've had is for a
long time particularly in mathematics
education it was felt that if you
practice too much that it would kill
your creativity and that's actually not
true you want to do the right kind of
practice where you're interleaving and
doing one technique and then trying that
with another technique you don't want to
just be doing the same thing over and
over again but practicing by here's a
good way to practice developing a chunk
let's say that you've got a homework
assignment and it's got this homework
problem and it's a really difficult
homework problem so what you tend to do
well you do it and you turn it in that
is the equivalent of you have just sung
a song one time and thinking that you
know how to sing that song beautifully
in front of an audience well it doesn't
work that way a good thing to do when
you're
learning something that's difficult is
find key in math key problems and then
see if we can work it cold if you can't
you take a peek at whatever he is you
need to be able to finish working it
then maybe a little later try working it
again cold without looking at the answer
and maybe you go further the next day
try to give go a little bit go a little
further and practice it what you're
trying to do is is to develop the same
patterns that you would develop if you
practice singing a song a number of
times and if you do this with key
problems in math or if you're learning a
language key conjugation patterns for
example then those patterns become
automatic so for example with your
problem after several days of practice
you find you've worked it out enough
times on pet by pencil that when you
just look at the problem you can step
through all the solution steps in your
mind you've created a valuable chunk and
so then when it comes test time and
you've got maybe five ten of these key
problems so you can just look at them
and know what you're supposed to be
doing
suddenly when you're taking that test
you can pull this chunk up and connect
it with this chunk then solve new
problems you haven't seen before and
it's a really really powerful technique
is to realize that all learning involves
giving these neural chunks together
you